-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody in the
Mountain time zone
[ Laughter ]
doing tonight?
Let's get to the news.
After an aide told
former President Trump
that there was no legal recourse
to stop late night comedy shows
from making fun of him,
Trump reportedly asked,
"Can something else be done
about it?"
Well, Donald, I'm pleased
to announce the answer is yes.
Here is my offer.
When Broadway comes back
in the fall,
you play Willy Loman
in "Death of a Salesman."
That's it.
That's all you have to do.
If you play Willy Loman
in "Death of a Salesman,"
we will not make fun of you
on "Late Night"
for the rest of the year.
But you have to be off-book.
If you forget your lines,
or, more likely,
don't read the script,
in the first place,
you just have
to make something up.
You just have to make up a plot
of whatever you think
[ Laughter ]
"Death of a Salesman" is about.
And, if you're wondering what
the catch is, there isn't one.
This is just something
I personally
would really enjoy seeing.
But if you don't do this,
well, then, I'm sorry,
but it's eclipse city in the
graphics department, baby.
[ Laughter ]
The White House
yesterday announced
which countries will receive
55 million doses
of the coronavirus vaccine.
And they were
pretty dramatic about it.
-Argentina!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Brazil!
Colombia!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-The Senate voted today
on the For the People
voting rights bill.
Republicans voted from the floor
between 6:00 am and 6:00 pm,
and Democrats voted
at an elementary school
30 miles away,
between noon and 12:15 pm.
New York prosecutors
are reportedly investigating
if Trump Organization
executives --
excuse me --
executive Matthew Calamari
received tax-free benefits
from the company.
Prosecutors aren't sure
if they really want Calamari,
or if he's just something
to pick at
while they wait
for the main course.
Do you get it?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, were you running lines
for "Death of a Salesman?"
[ Laughs ]
Texas Governor Greg Abbott
last week
signed a bill into law
allowing residents to carry
a handgun without a license.
So, the next time
the electrical grid collapses,
you'll at least feel
like you have power.
During a tele town hall
yesterday
about the For the People
voting rights bill,
former President Barack Obama
urged Senate Republicans not
to use the filibuster to block
a vote on the legislation.
Oh, yeah, well,
I'm sure they'll listen to you.
Why not have Hillary
and the cast of "Pose"
give them a call as well?
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
is reportedly planning
to announce a strategy to reduce
gun violence this summer,
but, before you give him
too much credit,
the plan is free knives.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Senator Joe Manchin
described growing up
in a big, Italian,
Appalachian family and said,
"I didn't care
what color you were.
I'm going to hug
and kiss you, first,
and then find out
if we're related."
[ As Giuliani ]
I go further than that!
Said Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter ]
And, again,
I really need to hammer home
this man married his cousin.
His second cousin.
He was married to a cousin,
divorced her,
and married a second cousin.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, oh.
Oh, second cousin.
But you believed it
for a second.
[ Laughter ]
While campaigning yesterday,
New York mayoral hopeful
and Brooklyn Borough President
Eric Adams
called rival candidate
Andrew Yang a fraud and a liar.
And then, Andrew Yang
called Brooklyn, "Brooklyin'."
Am I saying that right?
I think that's right.
[ Laughter ]
The members of the first
U.S. Olympic Skateboarding Team
were announced yesterday,
though I'd probably remind them
as it gets closer.
[ Laughter ]
Delta Airlines
announced yesterday
that it expects to hire
over 1,000 pilots
by next summer,
in order to meet
the growing travel demand.
Though this isn't
very reassuring --
[ Laughter ]
Amid a national shortage
of chicken wings,
restaurant chain Wingstop
has launched an online brand,
selling chicken thighs,
called Thighstop.
And things were even tougher
over at Buffalo Wild Beaks.
[ Laughter ]
Las Vegas Raiders defensive end
Carl Nassib yesterday
became the first active
NFL player in history
to come out as gay.
Said fans, "What?!
The Raiders play in Vegas now?!"
And, finally,
according to new study,
men who are unhappy
in their marriages are
at a higher risk of death.
As for men who are happy
in their marriages, why,
they're dead already.
[ Laughter ]
Baze.
Oh, I'm glad you laughed, Baze.
[ Laughter ]
Put me out there.
And that, you guys,
was the monologue.